bonsoir que le blanchemaison merci de
répondre à nos questions comment agir à
leroy selon vous selon les résultats de
ces élections évidemment
d'abord cette élection est très
importante pour le maroc et pour les
pays voisins y compris l'espagne et la
france qui sont les deux principaux
partenaires économiques
et puis demain en effet quelques grandes
villes marocaines vaut probablement
changer de majorité et par conséquent de
maire parce que les frères musulmans qui
sont dans le parti pour la justice et
développement n'ont pas démontré leur
efficacité dans la gestion municipale
alors pour le reste des veaux nationale
la constitution de 2011 que le roi a
dans lequel le roi a fait preuve d'un
certain libéralisme le fait que c'est
lui qui désigne le prochain premier
ministre
mais à charge pour ce premier ministre
de négocier une majorité avec les autres
partis de façon à disposer d'une
majorité à la chambre des représentants
alors ça veut dire que c'est le corps
électoral qui dévie la personne que le
que le petit kevin deux parties dans
lequel le roi choisira le futur premier
ministre et dans le fond il y à pas mal
de chances pour que ce soit le
rassemblement national des indépendants
qui cette fois ci prennent le pas sur le
parti pour la justice et le
développement les islamistes
actuellement au pouvoir
notamment parce que
monsieur aziz akhannouch qui est
actuellement le président de ce parti
indépendant de ce parti national des
indépendants est un homme d'affaires
important qui est passé par l'université
francophone de montréal de réformer le
parti a fait une tournée des 100 villes
principales pour récupérer les doléances
des électeurs et
c'est preuve d'un certain dynamisme il
n'aura pas la majorité par conséquent il
devra négocier avec les autres partis
probablement avec le parti de la justice
et du développement et cela cela
surveillance du roi parce que les
expériences de 2011 et 2016 ont montré
que le roi était très attentif pour les
mines et un cercle et qu'il avait ses
propres lignes rouges ses propres
candidats et deux de telle façon que par
exemple ce monsieur aziz akhannouch et
actuellement ministre de l'agriculture
dans le gouvernement deux frères
musulmans et qui va parfaitement réussie
dans un secteur qui rassemble 24% de la
population
le ministre des finances a également
parfaitement réussi c'est lui qui
agirait pour l'essentiel la crise du que
vide donc le roi va jouer un rôle
important dans la composition du
gouvernement et quels enjeux pour les
vainqueurs
écoutez l'enjeu c'est d'abord la
capacité à former ce gouvernement comme
je viens de l'expliquer c'est en
deuxième lieu la marge de manoeuvre
qu'ils réussiront à ceux créés par
rapport au palais au palais royal cette
marge de manoeuvre
elle est différente en fonction du
rapport de force le gouvernement
islamiste a été obligé d'accepter par
exemple l'établissement de relations
diplomatiques entre le maroc et israël
qui était contraire à sa plateforme
électorale
il a aussi été obligé d'accepter la
réintroduction du français dans les
écoles et des universités ce qui était
contraire à sa politique d'islamisation
la question est de savoir quelle sera la
marge de manoeuvre du prochain
gouvernement mais qu'elle sera aussi ça
sa capacité à définir un programme
économique et social de relance après la
crise du que vides
beaucoup d'experts claude annoncé une
abstention record si c'était avéré qu
est ce que ça traduirait
oui enfin c'est comme partout si si il y
à des abstentions
comme cela est probable bien que le
scrutin soit jumelé avec les scrutins
municipaux or les gens s'intéressent
plus à la gestion municipale parce que
ça c'est leur vie direct s'il y a
beaucoup d'abstention ça veut dire un
manque d'intérêt les électeurs pour le
débat politique ça veut dire aussi que
les partis politiques n'ont pas été
capables ou n'ont pas voulu faire
apparaître les vrais enjeux les vrais
débats entre différents projets entre
les options tranché cela dit les
marocains ont bien vu que les frères
musulmans avait les plus grandes
difficultés à gouverner en tunisie en
égypte en jordanie et même finalement en
turquie que les dérives technocratiques
du pjd et le manque de résultats
concrets dans la gestion du pays font
qu'il ya des affections des marocains
pour le personnel bolides y est que la
montée de partis plus proche du palais
comme le parti républicain on vient de
parler et bien
je le fais finalement
dépensé aux marocains que puis c'est
plus le palais qui m'a déterminé
l'orientation future de pays le projet
développement du pays que les électeurs
merci claude non je plaisante d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales